ce premier jour de déconfinement aussi
été marquée par le retour des gilet
jaune à paris ils étaient plusieurs
dizaines à s'être rassemblés place de la
république pour rendre hommage à l'un
d'entre eux qui seraient décédées ducobu
19 et forces de l'ordre sont intervenues
pour les disperser plusieurs d'entre eux
ont ensuite été verbalisé pour
participation à un rassemblement
interdit ou encore pour non respect de
la distanciation sociales et autres
actions de gilet jaune
aujourd'hui certains d'entre eux se sont
rendus au ministère de la santé pour
interpeller olivier vers ont écouté le
porte parole de l'assemblée des gilets
jaunes constitueront pourquoi le
ministère de la santé
parce que on estime que nous avons
beaucoup de comptes à leur demander et
maintenant voilà il nous faut faire des
actions coup de poing donc c'est pour ça
que nous sommes rentrés inter de la cour
et on voulait avoir
monsieur verrons où en un officiel le
président macron avait dit qu'il
étudierait toutes les voies possibles
pour gérer cette crise or ça fait deux
mois qu'on a la polémique sur le dr raou
et les médecins n'ont toujours pas le
droit de prescrire ce qu'ils veulent
alors heureusement on a des médecins qui
désobéissent et qui prescrivent et qui
traite qui soigne mais dans bien
d'autres cas on laisse les gens jusqu'à
temps qu'il soit voilà en détresse
respiratoire et autres manifestations à
toulouse cette fois devant l'hôpital de
purpan environ 150 personnes se sont
réunies à l'initiative des syndicats cgt
et sud les manifestants qui demandent
moins l'on songe illégalité et de mépris
notamment pour le personnel hospitalier
pouvait-on lire sur plusieurs affiches
géorgie les jaunes étaient également
présents aujourd'hui le personnel du chu
de tours ou appel au combat
aujourd'hui on est venus manifester pour
pour défendre le service public qui a
été attaquée qui est très clairement
on le voit avec la pandémie très
clairement l'hôpital est en souffrance
on le dit depuis des années je fais
partie de l'intérieur jean ça fait plus
d'un an qu'on se bat pour nos conditions
de travail et
et aujourd'hui on le voit avec la
pandémie l'hôpital public est en
souffrance on est en manque de moyens en
de personnel en 2 lits et donc on est là
pour pour ce défense décidera
aujourd'hui 1,5 ainsi les jeunes
venu pour soutenir les soignants obtenir
son lien avec tous les copains qu'ils
auront lieu au niveau des voies du
matériel de protection
surprise un jusqu'à manquer pendant
leur autre fils aimant pour leur
sécurité et celle mois et celle de
patients aussi puisque le relais